my name is Vladek and actually i want to
ask your permission to skip this whole
boring part of speaking about myself and
instead go straight to the topic that
really really want to hear about is that
okay great
cool so the topic I want to talk about
is messaging more specifically the
architectural pattern we usually call
events and the thing is events are
everywhere nowadays you know we have
event-driven architecture we have event
sourcing and of course we have micro
services hey many are calling for
integrating them asynchronously through
events as the default integration method
but this popularity came with the cost
some how many consider events to be some
kind of a magic sauce of distributed
systems as if you can take a monolith
pour some events over it and boom you've
got yourself micro services domain
driven design and overall modern a
distributed architecture and of course
that's not sure right this pattern is
not some kind of magic but it's just a
tool and as any tool you can use it to
create some great stuff but if you are
going to misuse or abuse it you're going
to pay a hell of a price for doing that
and fortunately or unfortunately I have
experience of doing both miss Susan
events and abusing them and in the next
40 minutes I will share my experience I
will show you the troubles I've got
myself into how we got out of those
troubles and most importantly what we
had learned along the way from that
experience but before we get those were
stories I want to start from the basics
I want to make sure that we are all on
the same page on what is software
architecture water its goals and what
exactly are those events that we are
talking about the worst stories that I
will share later are going to be based
heavily on this
theoretical part so what is a software
architecture when pondering this
question usually this quote comes to
mind architecture is about the important
stuff whatever that is
I guess no one would argue that it isn't
important right robust software
architecture is crucial not only for the
success of the system that we are
implementing but in many cases of the
whole organization that that software is
supposed to serve a for example in my
period previous workplace I was the
first employee so back then we had to
make a lot of architectural decisions we
had to decide for example whether to use
self-manage servers or go to the cloud
and nine years ago it wasn't a trivial
decision we had to choose languages
frameworks libraries and of course we
had to align the system's architecture
with this business domain which was
quite puzzling better than and all these
decisions were hard and risky you know
correct one would move the business
forward while a wrong decision would
make the system way harder to implement
and to maintain both in the short and in
the long terms so architectural
decisions are not only important but
they are also hard and complex therefore
in my opinion the goal of software
architecture is to manage complexity of
software systems and usually will manage
this complexity by dividing systems into
components into cells of interconnected
components we usually call them modules
those modules can appear at different
levels they can be methods classes
namespaces services even whole systems
but at whatever level they are the
underlying idea and the underlying
principles are still the same proper
modules negatory easier to reason about
the system as a whole and about each of
its components individually on the
architectural level much
reduces risk of those design decisions
that we are making it limits the scope
of each decision to the scope of the
module itself for example if you have a
service which uses a relational database
but for some reason we have to migrate
it to I don't know a document store that
change is going to affect that specific
module only and not the whole system put
differently modularity allows us to
divide the complexity of a system into
two types local complexity and global
complexity so local complexity is a
complexity of each individual component
and the easiest way to demonstrate this
notion is a simple simple heuristic I
like to use to evaluate it so let's say
we have a module and we have to ask how
easy or how hard would it be to
introduce a junior team member how hard
would it be for them to understand what
this module is supposed to do what
problem does it solve and how is it
implemented for example in our system
who had the module which was in charge
of a calculating commissions for sales
agents always public API resembled a
coherent set of methods in my way or
another related to those commissions now
because it's business domain was quite
limited
you know if the implementation was quite
predictable it was easy to find the way
around there on the other hand at one
point we had a module which was in
charge of managing and publishing
advertising campaigns managing creative
catalog and even taking care of the
company's finances billing at that case
forget about the junior developer some
points of time I had no idea what was
going on there so that second component
has a much higher local complexity
the second type of systems a complexity
is global complexity and this one is
defined by the level of
interconnectedness between the system's
components with low interconnectedness
it's easier to understand what role each
component plays in the system and it's
also easier to evolve those components
since change in one of them will have a
much lower impact on the rest of the
system and here we have an example of a
system and it's hard to tell when
objectively whether it has a high or low
global complexity but if we compare this
one to this system that it's evident
that here we have a higher global
complexity it's the same number of
components but they're much more
interconnected there are much more
dependencies and coupling between them
so this second system has a higher
global complexity so property a
components boundaries reduce complexity
of the system it makes it more adaptable
to future requirements and changes and
that makes the process of defining
components boundaries a key
architectural decision so if we go back
to the question of what is software
architecture in my opinion ruth milan
gave a crystal clear answer she said
that it's inherently about boundaries
what's in what's out what spans and what
moves between boundaries reshape what is
outside just as they shaped others
inside so systems design is about
drawing boundaries between
components and speaking of what moves
between those boundaries let's talk
about the pattern we often use for
decoupling components of a system events
and the idea behind this pattern is
fairly simple you know an event is a
message which is used as a contract for
integrating system systems sorry
usually that's what a typical message
looks like you know we have some
metadata that describe
the event who published it when why etc
and we have the payload which carries
the message itself that's the
information we want to communicate to
external systems now according to the
contents of that payload we can
categorize events into three types and I
took those definitions from Martin
Fowler's article called what you mean by
event-driven so the first one is what
Martin Fowler calls event notification
such event is used to notify that
something important has happened but it
contains minimal information on the
nature of the change if a subscriber
needs more data it can explicitly query
the source system to get further
information in some sense event
notification is like this weird thing
right here do you know what this is
Paige right so that's the idea you get
this message saying hey something is
going on but if you need more
information you have to call this number
that's the idea of event notification
the next type is what Martin Fowler
calls event carry at state transfer and
here the source system uses events to
notify subscribers about changes in that
system's internal state its data and
let's say we have this record of a
customer let's say we have a service
which manages customers and this service
is interesting interested in publishing
events which will describe changes in
the data of the customers it can do it
in two ways first it can publish a
complete snapshot of each customer so if
some field change we just take it as a
JSON and publish it to the message bus
there you've got it event carrier state
transfer of course if that customer has
hundreds of fields we can optimize it
and we can just publish the fields that
were actually changed
so only if two fields were changed you
just publish them either way all data
published by such events is sufficient
for the subscribers to hold a local
cache of that services data and work
with it they don't have to query the
publisher for additional information
like in the case of event notification
right and the final type is the events
used in domain driven design or for
event source and usually we call them
domain events and there are somewhere in
between those previous two types as
event notification they notify that
something important has happened but
they also carry enough data to describe
what actually happened this data however
should should be modelled as close as
possible to the business domain and not
some particular schedule presentation as
in the case of events for Karen changes
in state as Marian Duncan Jones says
here
stateless as the main event should be
stateless as regards to entity to which
the event occurred in other words money
deposit event holds no data on the
account balance so in this example
account balance is the state we are not
publishing it it's not a part of the
business domain on the other hand we do
have to specify the amount of money we
do have to specify who deposited the
money and to which account all the stuff
which describes what just happened in
the business domain so those are the
three types of events and to demonstrate
it I will use this example a my friend
from Israel Ora
it goes as she came up with this example
I really like it so let's say for
notification event we can have an event
which says marriage well we don't know
who married whom and where and when we
have to call the external system to get
that information
so that's notification event
on the other hand we have this personal
details changed and here we can see that
person's last name was changed you can
assume it was because of a marriage or I
don't know divorce or they just decided
to change their last name who knows but
we do get this state the current state
of that person so that event carries
state transfer and finally as a domain
event we can have person got married
here we have a idea of the person who
got married we have the partner ID we
can have a flag which says whether that
person assumed the partners last night
it will be true or false
but we don't hold the current last name
that would be a state projection that
belongs to the second type now it's
crucial to choose the correct event type
for a specific task events they are
going through the boundaries of those
services that we are implementing and
their inherent part of those boundaries
and if you saw in the previous part
boundaries are a crucial architectural
decision so if we choose correct type of
events for the task great we'll get a
more decoupled system but if you are
making a mistake here it can lead us to
accidental complexities and even the
dreaded distributed monolith and to
demonstrate it I want to share some war
and horror stories from my experience at
a company called inter novice at
internal was our goal was to allow
companies that are producing products or
services to outsource their marketing
related chores so come up with marketing
strategies would create creative
materials we would publish them as
advertising campaigns aggregate leads
and eventually we'll call those needs to
sell the products pretty complex and
wide business domain and as it usually
happens initially we try to implement
this whole thing as one huge monolith
now complexity wise you know this
some had very low global complexity
because hey you have only one component
can be cannot be coupled to itself so
the global complexity was minimal on the
other hand the local complexity of that
component was huge everything was
implemented in it now unsurprisingly
after some time this design started
breaking under its own weight
you know this code base became slow hard
to test and overall the development
process became unpredictable so we
decided to break this monolith into two
subsystems we called it marking and CRM
that's what it looked like marking
system was in charge of collecting and
publishing marketing events for example
impression click submit' atleat etc and
it was kind of stupid it didn't really
do anything with those events
apart from publishing them to the
subscribers those subscribers on the
other hand they were free to do whatever
they want with those events however as
time passed we notice that all those
subscribers did exactly the same thing
they projected they transformed those
marketing events into exactly the same
state representation now it's important
to point out that this wasn't a mere
projection but it calculated different
metrics for each event just it didn't
just you know transform the model into
something else not just moving those
fields around instead it had some
complex business logic which calculated
business values for example is this
event coming from and you lead or an
existing customer if it's a new lead
then what was the cost of gaining it if
that's a customer an existing one there
what's their projected lifetime value of
that customer etc etc and there were
many such calculations and some of them
were really complex now not only that
there were complex because that
code was duplicated each time it was
modified we had to modify it all those
subscribers at the same time and of
course the hard parts they had to change
the most the most like most frequently
and of course what we are seeing here is
a very strong coupling between those
subscribers also on the left side here
we were quickly hit in the face by
unreliable reliability of the network
because we namely assume that you know
the events that we are publishing
they're going to be delivered exactly in
the same order as they are published and
also that each event is going to be
delivered only once as if this whole
system acted as one big illogical
transaction of course that wasn't the
case and the moment things didn't go as
planned the same events produced
different results for different
subscribers now to fix this we try to
employ some infrastructural black magic
in order to charging for this
transaction this huge distributed
transaction but what we eventually did
was just raise the local complexity of
those components in the maximum on top
of the huge global complexity that we
already had there so eventually we solve
this by refactoring that marketing
system into an event sourcing based
system it would encapsulate all that
complex and volatile business logic and
instead of publishing mere notification
events now it emitted more elaborate
domain events that described what has
actually happened in the business domain
and if you if we were to look at this
from complexity standpoint this
refraction lowered both the global
complexity of the whole system and also
the local complexity of its components
because now we removed
that code that was duplicated in all
those subscribers now speaking of that
CRM system originally we implemented it
in you know a traditional way it stores
its data in a relational database now
after some time we of course understood
that this implementation was limiting us
in a number of ways first it didn't
scale second that relational model was
limiting us it limited the insights that
we were able to get from that data our
business stakeholders wanted more
flexible ways of looking at that
information so we decided to refactor
this in the CRM into an event sourcing
and Secours based system our initial
Secours implementation was pretty much
by the book you know the client would
submit the command its execution would
result in new domain events appended to
the event store and it projected a
project and those main events were
projected into view models and finally
the commands results were communicated
back to the user from the read model
those are the so-called one-way commands
the information flows only in one
direction here the thing is there are no
commands here what we are having here on
the left side is events masquerading as
commands because a system should be able
to refuse execution of a command and of
course to communicate back to the caller
the reason why the command was not
executed was there a technical issue or
maybe the command isn't valid if it's
invalid tell the user how to fix it
right and in this case the CRM systems
user experience was terrible because of
this long feedback loop so to fix this
we decided to do something risky you
know I I was honestly afraid that some
people in the community will be willing
to burn
to death death you know as a traitor
because I said we take this segregation
command query segregation and we'll
relax it our commands from now on can
return information for example if you
call the command synchronously you will
get the answer did it succeed or did it
fail if it felt why it failed and this
change dramatically improved the user
experience you know the users were
getting getting the results of their
actions immediately moreover in some
cases instead of querying the
projections for the updated view models
we returned the updated data as part of
the common execution object as well
because let's say our user updates a
information about some customer it's
okay and then he is presented with stale
data you know whatever we have in
projections terrible user experience so
instead we just return the updated
information as part of the command as
well the only limitation of course is
that this information can only come from
a strongly consistent data store from
the event store in our case because
again projections are eventually
consistent we cannot trust them to be
refreshed immediately so whatever we
could we just returned as a part of the
command and again it improved the user
experience of the system now the users
didn't had to you know refer the screen
to get the up-to-date information now
let's speak about those projections so
the CRM system published those domain
events as its public API and it expected
other systems to leverage this freedom
of generating their own projections at
the beginning it looked awesome you know
especially when we compared this to the
initial a relational database based
design however after the securest
honeymoon period was over we
suddenly realized that 90% of those
subscribers projected exactly the same
model and again as in the case of
marketing this a marketing system this
introduced a logical coupling the logics
that projected events into a workable
state was duplicated in all those
subscribing components now not only was
it duplicated but because it held the
knowledge of how each domain event
affects the state it was tightly coupled
to the serums implementation details the
CRM system exposed many different types
of events I think about 200 event types
and all those subscribers had to closely
follow changes in the serums
implementation and of course it changed
often and if a new event type was
introduced those subscribers have to
reflect that immediately why because if
that you event a new type of event
somehow affects value of a projected
field then ignoring this new event will
result in an inconsistent state so to
sum it up again from the complexity
standpoint we have here implementation
coupling we'll have here logical
coupling and this red things red thing
just screams simplify me the system is
too complex so to decouple this mess we
encapsulated that projection logic in
the CRM system itself and instead of
exposing hundreds of domain events it
published it published changes to the
projected state through event carried
state transfer effectively this serums
public API compressed its implementation
details those hundreds of event typed
into a much more restricted set of
public events that just described in all
the changes in that projected state
now of course it did raise the local
complexity of the serum system a bit
because we introduced new logic but
again no big deal that change
dramatically improved the global
complexity of the whole system the next
story is about a betrayal so we have
this nice micro-services based system
you know low global complexity and
actually low local complexity of the
components and then because of some new
requirements we had to introduce an
additional micro service that new micro
service had to process data from all
other services do some work make some
decisions and communicate those
decisions back to those micro services
now what we really have here in the
middle is not a micro service but an
architectural Trojan horse because this
thing turned this whole system into a
coupled mess the it somehow got coupled
to the implementation details of each of
those micro services the original ones
and not only that the horse got coupled
to the rest of the system the rest of
the system got coupled to the horses and
implementation details so every time one
of them had to change almost always the
rest of the services had to change as
well now needless to say that in this
case the global complexity just
skyrocketed right now the solution that
we used was domain driven design
anti-corruption layer pattern we used it
you know to separate the integration
complexity from the business complexity
of that new service the ACLS local
complexity was really low all it had to
do is just aggregate data and transform
it into another model the more complex
service the original Trojan horse ended
up encapsulating the complexity of the
business domain
it wasn't so coupled to the rest of the
system anymore
so even though its implementation had to
change frequently you know it doesn't
really impact the rest of the system at
most it just impacted that
anti-corruption layer in the middle now
Nicktoons thinks he speaks about a very
similar idea he just calls it a funnel
context he worked on this idea a bit
more and it's not just an
anti-corruption layer as I described in
domain-driven design so if it's if it
sounds useful to you look for nicotine
funnel context now the story of the next
system started pretty similarly to the
previous one actually it was our first
step at implementing a micro services
based system so how should we design it
and we said hey micro services that
micro part is there for a reason so
we'll design those services as small as
possible and of course we'll integrate
them asynchronously through events
mainly through events now look look nice
initially as it always happens but as we
implemented more and more features those
services became more and more chatty you
know almost each of them at some point
needed data from all other services to
complete some of its operations so what
started as a decouple system it actually
ended up being a distributed monolith
now of course to implement it what did
we do we just poured the magic sauce of
distributed system systems we just added
more events to publish and to subscribe
to again global complex this skyrocketed
now the reason for this distributed
monolith and the reason for all those
events we had to exchange here it wasn't
a real problem
it was the symptom the same the symptom
of
the composition of a system into
components so what we had to do here is
to take a step back and rethink the
boundaries we had to merge some of those
services together some state
independence some some business
functionalities had to be moved across
those boundaries but eventually that
refraction will led to a system with
much less events flowing between the
components now for this last story I
cannot trash-talk too much here because
I wasn't directly involved in this
implementation so try to watch my
language so about a few years ago in
turn oboes was merged with another
company and here is what I stumbled upon
when we did some architectural reviews
the goal of using events here is to
build a distributed scalable system
let's see what you really have here
first of all how this thing works
users are executing commands those
commands write and write some
information to relational database and
then some events are published to a
message bus subscribers pick up those
events from the message bus and do some
stuff now the first thing that we have
here is transactional coupling between
the database and the message bus because
what will happen if the process will die
exactly after committing the database
transaction but just before the event
was published in the message bus the
user will get an error data some data
will be written some will be lost and
the end result is data corruption also
for all those subscribers the order of
the events was important but it wasn't
enforced by the producer so that's
additional dimension of transactional
coupling
now let's see what those subscribers are
actually doing the first one is simple
it just picks up those messages and
records them to some persistent storage
the second one projects a state
representation of that business entity
into sound in-memory cache in-memory
database
the third one forwards those events to
BI for analysis but first it enriches
all those incoming events with the state
from that cash from the second pull a
subscriber so effectively these two
subscribers the last two they're
temporarily coupled to each other they
should be executed in a specific order
or otherwise the analysis model is going
to be enriched with inconsistent state
now of course such orchestration may be
as possible in some cases but in our
case we just hoped for the best
and eventually the data just got
corrupted now to fix all this mess what
we did is we employed the out box
pattern you know we just leveraged the
relational database that we already had
it there we just expanded that original
transaction to write information to one
more table twelve box out box we
recorded those events that need to be
published one transaction now the user
would get the result of the action once
that transaction was completed and then
some relay would pick those messages
from the table and publish them to the
message bus now that was a very trivial
for us to do because again we already
had a relational database and was very
easy you know to implement a writing to
multiple tables in the same transaction
and again it eliminated eliminated all
that transactional coupling that we had
in that system initially
now those are the stories that I wanted
to share now let's see what we had
learned from that experience so first of
all when designing event-driven systems
be pessimistic about everything not
naively assumed that things will just
work things won't just work and trust me
on that one they will fail the most on
weekends that works
don't don't test that assumption and you
know in that last system what we had
here is I call it optimistic consistency
you're optimistic that things will just
work
they didn't what we got here is eventual
data corruption and you know that term
event-driven architecture it has this
word driven for reason your whole system
depends on delivery of those events so
make sure the events are delivered no
matter what even if the system crashes
in the middle or there is a network
outage or the message bus got crazy and
you know delivered the same event ten
times your subscribers should be able to
handle that situation as well
next identify private and public events
some events you know are just
implementation details especially domain
events in event sort system systems now
it might be tempting you know to expose
them as the public interface but you do
not want external systems to depend on
your implementation details right you
want to be able to change the
implementation of your service freely
without affecting unrelated external
systems so instead leverage both public
and private events private events can be
very detailed domain events and you can
have them as many as you need however
when designing your public api's
compress those private events into a
more restricted set of public events
those public events should be modeled
for the purpose of integrations with
external systems they should be more
stable than the implementation details
of the service that is publishing them
also we saw that there are three
different types of events use them all
notification events and event carried
State transfer are great for integrating
services the main events are great for
modeling business domains and of course
instead of blindly integrating
micro-services asynchronously through
events evaluate their consistency
requirements you know if you've got two
services that can settle for eventual
consistency great integrate them
asynchronously if two events but if one
of them expects to read the last write
of the second one maybe it will be
easier to just issue a synchronous call
and get the most up-to-date data if you
still need push-based
integration then you can publish an
event notification you know that first
type and then the subscribers will have
to explicitly query the source system
for the most most up-to-date data that
they have and finally if on the other
hand you have two services and they
share a set of methods that assume some
kind of concurrency control between them
in other words only one of them can
change some specific set of data
simultaneously then stop right there
probably you have your boundaries wrong
you have to align your service
boundaries with the boundaries of your
business domain that was yeah that was
the situation in the story of those tiny
micro services that I've shown you
earlier right so
also three lessons that I wanted to
share and I think it stopped time to
wrap this whole thing up so quick
summary the goal of software
architecture is to manage complexity we
manage complexity of software by using
modules by using modules we have to deal
with global complexity the level of
interconnectedness of the systems
components and local complexities of
each components we have three types of
events notification event something
interesting has happened we have event
carry state transfer for publishing
changes in data and we have domain
events which notified that something
interesting has happened in the business
domain and what we have learned from
that experience be pessimistic assume
that things will fail things won't work
make sure your events are delivered no
matter what use private and public
events to limit the public API of your
components and evaluate consistent
consistency requirements to choose the
correct way of integrating services and
all this actually brings us back to the
topic of what's the goal of software
architecture and how modules allow us to
manage complexity so if we get those
event wrong
we actually mess those boundaries and as
Ruth Malan said that's a key
architectural decision
and before we go - I see that we have
two questions here I have a minute for a
shameless plug so first of all not long
ago I published a small book on
domain-driven design the name is simple
what is domain driven design it's really
a short read and the goal here is to
introduce the basic notion of what is
DDD water its core principles and how
you can apply some of its components on
your brownfield projects you know
without going crazy with the Skoll
methodology it's available on all
Reilly's online learning platform that's
the link it's like Netflix for books but
you get the first week for free
registering second if you already know
what is domain driven design then I
shared the story of our company how we
use domain driven design for seven years
you can find that story as a chapter in
the book called domain driven design the
first 15 years actually that that's one
you can get for free if you follow the
link you just set your own price if you
want to work with me change a check the
careers we have and do it international
and if I still didn't bore you to death
that's my twitter and now I will get the
questions are you suggesting components
are coupled when they maintain similar
logical views where is the coupling so
if they contain the same business logic
which produces those views and you know
those components have to change because
for the same reason then you have
coupling if accidentally for example you
have two components producing the same
view or you know it's not really
important to involve them simultaneously
then there are naturally coupled so it
really depends on the reasons for change
the second question is how is the outbox
pattern any different what to prevent
the power outage for breaking the new
flow so once we get that
a approval from the database that
transaction was committed the data is
there the relay which runs
asynchronously will pick that message up
either now or even in an hour but that
event is still going to be published
also because we are writing those events
into the same table we can use the
tables index you know to check the order
in which order those events who are
written do we have any more questions
come on people don't be shy okay if you
have any questions I'm here thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]